Democrats claim that criticism of
representative Ilhan Omar is incitement
share becomes a Republican and mayor
Pete officially launches his campaign
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show oh man a lot to get to today we
will get to all of it including a game
of thrones recap a little later in the
show but first in 2008 the US national
debt was 10 trillion dollars today the
debt is nearly 22 trillion dollars it is
rising like a hockey stick if you do not
think that we are sitting on a house of
cards you're living with their head in
the sand but since you listen to my
podcast you're clearly smarter than the
average bear so what is your plan can
you afford another hit to your
retirement like the last downturn when
the S&P dropped 50% hedge against
inflation hedge against uncertainty and
instability with precious metals gold is
a safe haven against uncertainty my
savings plan is diversified and yours
should be to the company that i trust
with precious metal purchases is Birch
gold group and right now thanks to a
little-known IRS tax law you can even
move your IRA or eligible 401k into an
IRA backed by physical gold and silver
which is good for some people who may
want to protect their hard-earned
retirement savings from future
geopolitical uncertainty if you look
back historically when the bottom falls
out of everything else
Gold tends to save car savings it has
never been worth zero Birch gold group
has thousands of satisfied customers
countless five-star reviews and a plus
rating from the Better Business Bureau
contact Birch gold group get a free
information kit on physical precious
metals see if diversifying into gold and
silver makes him sense for you this
comprehensive 16 page kit reveals how
gold and silver can protect your savings
how you can legally move that IRA or
401k out of stocks and bonds into a
precious metal metals IRA if that's
something you are interested in to get
that no-cost no-obligation kit text been
- 47 47 47 again text been my name - 47
47 47 been - 47 47 47 alright so over
the weekend we have a brand new brand
new narrative from the Democrats the
narrative is if you're mean to Democrats
you're inciting violence now this is
nothing new this is nothing new this has
been going on for quite a while when I
spoke at Berkley in 2017 there were
people outside my speech chanting speech
is violence now of course this is
idiotic speech is not violence and the
First Amendment is predicated on the
notion that speech is not violence that
if I say something critical of you I am
not being violent toward you and you can
rebut my statement without you being
violent toward me the moment we equate
speech with violence we have now
provided an excuse for government to
step in and shut down speech because
after all it is the government's job to
prevent externalities the basic rule of
thumb when it comes to government as
articulated by John Stuart Mill is you
get to wave your hand around in any
direction until you hit me in the face
well that's how speech works I get to
say whatever I want and so long as I am
not actively inciting violence telling
people to come to your house and kill
you or encouraging people to do so as
long as I'm not doing those things I am
NOT inciting violence and in fact it is
more likely to break down our public
discourse for you to continually suggest
that I am inciting violence then is my
criticism of you to suggest that
somebody is speaking in a way that
incites violence when they are not in
fact inciting violence is merely an
excuse to silence them and this is the
latest Democratic tactic after the
Democrats have spent years demonizing
Republicans after they have said that
Donald Trump is not human representative
Ilhan omar said about three weeks ago
that donald trump was not a human being
after the democrats demonized Brett
Kavanaugh calling him a gang rapist
after they suggested that the Covington
boys the Covington Catholic High School
boys were a bunch of racist bigots after
all of that now the Democrats have
suggested that if you critique Ilhan
Omar for being soft on 911 and being
soft on terrorism more broadly you're
inciting violence against her this is
sheer crap and it is not only that and
his badly motivated crap it is designed
to protect Ilhan Omar at the expense of
the truth and at the expense of her own
views being promulgated her own views
are very bad she has a right to them but
if we repeat her own words back to her
that is her problem not ours it's pretty
astonishing to watch as members of the
press do this routine it's one thing for
Democrats you expect Democrats to be
badly motivated and how they attack
Republican speech they've been doing
this for a very long time never mind
that after a Bernie Sanders supporter
went and shot up a congressional
baseball game nearly murdered the House
Majority Whip at the time Steve Scalise
there was zero discussion about Bernie
Sanders's rhetoric and whether it
incited violence although you can
certainly say that if the new standard
of Democrats that extreme rhetoric that
loud rhetoric that hot rhetoric that
that incites violence if you use that
standard then Bernie Sanders is guilty
but I don't agree that that standard
should be used and at the time neither
did Democrats neither did the media
well now the media have
changed their tune everything that
President Trump says incites violence
everything said against Republicans is
basically justified when Michael knows
works for us over at Daily wire went to
a university just last week and somebody
physically assaulted him by spraying him
with a liquid that at the time people
thought was bleach when that happened
the Kansas City Star came forward and
suggested that knowles and the person
who shot him with liquid were engaged in
a tit-for-tat
so in other words knowles said stuff and
somebody assaulted him and those were
the same thing when i was on national
television and i was talking to a
transgender person by the name of zoe
term and i terms o eater sir because the
entire question was about whether
biological males can be females and then
zoe turn proceeded to grab me by the
back of the neck on national television
and threatened to send me home in an
ambulance the media treated it as though
my words and his actions were equivalent
so this is nothing new the media's been
doing this for a very long time
anytime somebody on the right says
something the left does not like the
left suggest that it is incitement and
anytime the left does something the left
suggests that it was incited by the
right not by their own rhetoric on the
left the latest example of this is ill
Hunnam are of course so representative
omar last week was caught on tape saying
that 9/11 was some people did something
direct quote some people did something
and people said um that's a pretty
disparaging way of talking about 9/11
now I looked at that tape and I thought
yeah she's obviously sort of dismissing
it and if it's within a broader
worldview of her dismissing terrorism I
read you twice last week on the podcast
I read you twice on the radio show the
letter that she sent to a judge in 2016
in which she recommended leniency for
people who joined Isis on the grounds
that they had been marginalized this is
a person who suggested in a column in
Time magazine that America was founded
on slavery and genocide and in order to
avoid discussing that we had cast
aspersions at international terrorism
this is not somebody who takes terrorism
seriously but if you mention any of that
if you quote her and if you draw a
conclusion then this apparently is
tantamount to some sort of incitement
now President Trump jumped on the
bandwagon on Friday he tweeted out a
video that his team put together of ill
Hannum are talking about 9/11 along with
footage from 9/11 to remind everybody
that if you are dismissing 9/11 here is
what you are too
missing care was founded after 9/11
because they recognized that some people
did something you have no idea rather
I'd have another one another plane just
hit some people did something oh my
goodness there is smoke today some
people did something if just flew
straight into it
some people did something right so this
is the video video is this is September
11 2001 we remember because again the
idea here is that it's not some people
did something here is what happened and
you remember what happened this was not
some people did something so President
Trump
tweets this out and people get very
angry at him for having juxtaposed her
words with the footage of 9/11 oh it's
just so terrible how could he do such a
thing how about she said what she said
and then the footage juxtaposed to what
she said that's not only in elements of
free speech that is also a fair critique
of ill Hunnam are not taking 9/11
seriously enough but here's what this
prompted representative Omar still has
not said what would be the easiest thing
in the world to say seriously we've been
the easiest thing
the day after representative Dan
Crenshaw tweeted out the video the day
after it started being publicized all
Ilhan omar had to say is my broader
point was obviously it wasn't obvious
but my broader point was obviously that
people who are not the mainstream of the
Muslim world committed an awful evil
terrorist act and then the impact was on
Muslims more broadly and that was a
terrible thing but I never meant to
downplay
9/11 and any suggestion that I did is
off-base that's all she had to say she
still has not said that she still has
not said those things instead she has
doubled down on this stuff she tweeted
out a quote from george w bush and
suggested that george w bush minimised
9/11 which is a joke it is not close to
true well now her new tech is everyone's
being mean to me welcome to politics
representative omar everybody's mean to
me she tweeted out we are all americans
this is endangering lives it has to stop
really is this endangering lives really
weird Ilhan omar because I seem to
remember when three times in the last
four months you have made openly
anti-semitic statements who claims that
Jews were engaged in dual loyalty and
Israel supporters were engaged in dual
loyalty for the State of Israel you
suggested that American Jewish money was
behind the American support for Israel
and you suggested also that the Jews
were responsible for for hypnotizing the
world I mean all of this happened in the
last four months over and over and over
you said anti-semitic things and hate
crimes against Jews are up significantly
around the world and particularly in the
United States I don't remember
the arguments about Ilhan Omar's
language helping to incite violence you
know why because she wasn't inciting
violence even though what she was saying
was vile and terrible and hate-filled
that still was not inciting violence and
yet according to ohon Omar if you quote
her its inciting violence quote we are
all Americans this is endangering lives
it has to stop and then she puts out
this long statement on Twitter since the
president's tweet Friday evening I have
experienced an increase in direct
threats on my life many directly
referencing or replying to the
president's video I think the Capitol
Police the FBI the house
sergeant-at-arms and the Speaker of the
House for their attention to these
threats violent crimes and other acts of
hate by right-wing extremists and white
nationalists are on the rise in this
country and around the world ok first of
all it is not totally clear that other
acts of hate by right-wing extremists in
the United States are actually on the
rise in this country there are more
reporting agencies but put that aside
even assume that's true what in the
world does that have to do with Trump
tweeting out a video of you saying
things juxtaposed to the thing you're
talking about and then she continues we
can no longer ignore that they are being
encouraged by the occupants of the
highest office in the land country
counties that hosted a 2016 Trump rally
so a 226 percent increase in hate crimes
in the months following the rally an
assault increase when cities host Trump
rallies this is particularly concerning
giving the president's visit to my home
state of Minnesota on Monday violent
rhetoric and all forms of hate speech
have no place in our society much less
from our country's commander-in-chief we
are all Americans this is endangering
lives it has to stop ok question we
played the video was anything in there a
form of hate speech was it violent
rhetoric or is it simply quoting her
next to footage of the things she was
talking about this playing victim
routine where she is a prominent
politician on the cover of national
magazines on the cover of Rolling Stone
alongside Nancy Pelosi and the idea is
that if you quote her and you point out
that she has a perverse worldview that
when you suggest that that that is some
sort of initiation or incitement of
violence against her this is a pure easy
tactic for shutting down debate for
shutting down speech that's what this is
and I take my share of crap let me tell
you I have security nearly full time and
I have for at this point months and
years because of the amount of hate and
the number of death threats that I get
and you know what people are still
allowed to criticize me I've never
called for anyone to be banned from
Twitter
I've never called for anyone to be
banned from Facebook I've never called
for the police to go and arrest any of
my critics
I've never suggested that people who
criticize me are inciting violence no
matter how vile or out of context they
are and yet if you're ohon Omar the
media will parrot this that's the part
that's astonishing
these First Amendment loving media
members who say that Trump is shutting
down free speech they will jump right on
the bandwagon when it comes to Donald
Trump is somehow inciting violence in
violation of the First Amendment it's
insane I'll get some more of this in
just a second first getting fit and
staying healthy always sounds easier
said than done all right we'll open fit
is bringing you something new that makes
it even easier to never miss a sweat
session lose the commute to the gym let
the workouts come to you open if it
takes all the complexity out of losing
weight and getting fed I like to work
out every day and open if it makes it
possible when I'm on the road every
night when I go home my wife who works
very long hours who workout together
using open fit open fit is a brand-new
super simple streaming service that
allows you to workout from the comfort
of your living room in as little as 10
minutes a day everybody's bodies are
different open fit gets that that's why
it is personalized to your needs with
custom tailored original content open
fit classes are led by some of the most
effective and engaging trainers in the
world
forget all the complexity and stress
around getting fit just press play and
workout on your schedule 600 seconds
with celebrity trainer Devon Wiggins it
packs the fat burning muscle building
and body sculpting benefits of much
longer sessions into a fraction of that
time you can view it on your computer or
web enabled TV tablet smartphone Roku
lose up to 15 pounds in just the first
30 days flatten your abs shape your body
look and feel great as I say my wife and
I use open fit ourselves it really is
fantastic it's great open fit has
changed the way I work out with my coach
Shapiro you can join me on a fitness
journey personalized just for you again
use my code Shapiro start using open fit
for your journey to a healthier life
right now during the open fit 30-day
challenge my listeners get a special
extended 30-day free trial so give it a
try
you can lose up to 15 pounds in 30 days
text Shapiro to 30 30 30 you get the
full access to open fit all the workouts
all the nutrition information totally
free just extra pro2 30 30 30 standard
message and data rates may apply open
fit is fantastic again I can't I can't
tell you how great it is because my wife
and I use it it's really terrific okay
so the press and the Democrats keep
pushing forward this narrative the
president Trump and people who have
criticized al-haram are representative
Dan Crenshaw they're responsible for
incitement
it demonstrates the full scale bad faith
people making the argument particularly
in the press when you look at the sort
of rhetoric that the left has been using
for years at this point years the
Southern Poverty Law Center labeled the
Family Research Council a hate group
just within within a few weeks a person
named why I won't name him cuz he was a
shooter a shooter walked into the
headquarters at the Family Research
Council and shot up the Family Research
Council and nearly killed the guard an
armed guard the Southern Poverty Law
Center continued to be used as a source
by most of the media until their well
deserved collapse in the last couple of
months Bernie Sanders again what if his
supporters shot up at Congressional
baseball game moves out of the news
inside of a week Donald Trump tweets out
a video that includes a quote from a
sitting congresswoman who is on the
House Foreign Affairs Committee
juxtaposed with the things she's talking
about and this is incitement to violence
this is obviously about Donald Trump
being evil it's insipid and it's in it's
bad faith garbage designed to prevent
anyone from discussing the reality of
Ilhan Omar's views which are egregiously
radical egregiously radical across the
board and particularly when it comes to
foreign policy meanwhile other members
of Congress are jumping on the bandwagon
with this sort of garbage AOC tweeted
out the worst version of this last week
I mean this is this is just beyond
insane
it's beyond insane it's actually
despicable what she tweeted out so she
tweeted out this wonderful fresh face of
the Democratic Congress quote members of
Congress have a duty to respond to the
president's explicit attack today
Ilhan Omar's life is in danger for our
colleagues to be silent is to be
complicit in the outright dangerous
targeting of a member of Congress we
must speak out first they came for the
Socialists okay and then she tweets out
that famous poem from the Rev Reverend
niemöller I believe the the first they
came for the Socialists and I was not a
socialist so I said nothing and then
they came for the the trade unionists
and then they came for the Jews and then
finally when they came for me there was
no one left to speak out for me
so she's invoking the Holocaust she's
invoking the Holocaust in order to
defend the worst anti-semite in Congress
so Ilhan Omar who keeps saying antes
medic things over and over and over to
the point where members of her own party
have gone to AIPAC and condemned her I'm
talking specifically about Stinney Hoyer
the House Majority Whip he goes to AIPAC
and condemns her Ilhan Omar is now being
equated to Jews historically and Jews
were murdered in the Holocaust so in
other words Donald Trump quoting a
sitting member of Congress is the same
as Donald Trump liquidating people like
johann Omar that's what this is do you
know insulting and disgusting that is it
really is and then you have radicals
insane people like max Bergeron you can
see the true agenda here in this
particular tweet max Berger happens to
be the co-founder of if not now which is
a wildly anti-israel far-left garbage
organization it spends most of it stays
slandering Israel and trying to make
make time for on on behalf of of terror
apologists so Max Berger tweets out Jews
need to understand that Muslims now play
the role we have played throughout our
history
they are blamed for the failures of
people in power in this time of rising
fascism American Jews must defend ail
Han Omar and our Muslim brothers and
sisters with all our might if I if I
could I would flip the double bird - max
Berger what a disastrous disgusting
piece of garbage tweet that as my
goodness Muslims play the role that Jews
at play really who are the leading
targets of hate crime for the last 20
years in the United States year-on-year
it's always Jews there are 50 Muslim
states on planet Earth there is one
Jewish state and that Jewish state is
under constant rocket barrage from a
terrorist group Muslims play there 1.8
billion Muslims on planet Earth there 14
million Jews Muslims play the rule that
Jews play throughout history under what
but this is the intersection of what
worldview huh no markets to say whatever
that f she wants about Jews because the
ohan Omar is a Somali woman who is
Muslim and so she gets to say whatever
she wants about Jews she gets to say
whatever she wants about 9/11 and no one
is supposed to say anything and if you
say something you're inciting against
her and victimizing her and the Jews who
are victimized by Ilhan Omar the Jews
who are who are called dual loyalists
the Jews who it is suggested are the are
the font and the wellspring of evil in
the world by people like Kohanim are
they are hypnotizing the world those
people really need to point they need to
just cede the mantle of victimhood to
OHANA Maher who really
the true victim a young woman who has
spent some time in America
she's been her since 12 since age 12 a
refugee taken in by the most generous
country on the face of the earth and
then put in Congress with no record
other than being herself that's it truly
astonishing but don't worry guys we have
to we must defend a lejano mark bend the
ark another anti Israel you know front
group
they call themselves Jewish action but
this isn't an anti Jewish group they
they tweeted out shabbat shalom - illa
Hannah Martin our black and Muslim
family the attacks on you from her the
president are violent and unconscionable
violent were they violence attacks cuz
it seems to me the Jews have experience
in violence attacks before violent
attacks our Jewish community has your
back we will not be silent we will keep
fighting for a world where your faith
and your leadership I respected the only
way I have Ilhan Omar's back is that she
has the right to say what she wants to
say every other way I absolutely do not
have her back and neither to the vast
majority of Jews in the country who have
been targeted by her hateful rhetoric
over and over and over again and I don't
care how many covers of magazines she
appears on and I don't give a damn how
many Democratic leaders come out and
suggest that she is the victim of
violence she was criticized that is not
the same thing as being a victim of
violence and if people send her death
threats those people should be arrested
but that is not the same thing as the
president pointing out a thing she said
Nancy Pelosi playing the same stupid
game she tweeted out Donald Trump's
dangerous video must be taken down I
have spoken with the sergeant-at-arms to
ensure the Capitol Police are conducting
a security assessment to safeguard
representative Omar her family and her
staff they will continue to monitor and
address the threats she faces and then
she tweeted out following the
president's suite I spoke with the
sergeant-at-arms and then it's her and
then says the president's words weigh a
ton and his hateful and inflammatory
rhetoric creates real danger creates
real danger Nancy Pelosi said that
Americans were collateral damage of
President Trump's policies Democrats day
after day after day have suggested that
the President of the United States is
Russian agent they've said that you're
going to die because of net neutrality
they're going to die because of global
warming they're gonna die because of his
tax cuts none of that was incitement you
know why cuz it wasn't incitement it's
stupid it's hateful it's not incitement
and yet Democrats demonstrating the
death of the liberal mental
that I disagree with what you say but
I'll die for your right to say it
they've decided no instead you should
shut you should shut up and if you say
anything we'll just call it in citement
how convenient and it's not just Nancy
Pelosi of course you got Bernie Sanders
coming forth and saying this he tweets
out
Ilhan Omar is a leader with strength and
courage of course Bernie Sanders says
this there's no more anti-israel
candidate on planet Earth
he says she won't back down to Trump's
racism and hate neither will we the
disgusting and dangerous attacks against
her must end just dangerous attacks
against her one of your supporters shot
up a bunch of Congress people about two
years ago dude I don't remember a huge
conversation about your dangerous
attacks on everybody who opposed your
medicare-for-all plan which you said was
responsible for the people's refusal of
that plan was responsible for tens of
thousands of dead according to you I
don't remember that conversation being
called dangerous you know why cuz it's
not dangerous if I seem exercised about
this that's because I am it's an absurd
disgusting contention designed it's
sapping the strength of our republic the
strength of our republic is that you can
say something and I can say something
and that's not called violence and yet
Democrats want to say that this is all
called violence as long as it's somebody
on the right saying it it's nothing but
bad faith censorship and that's what
they're attempting right now coming up
in a second I'll show you some more some
more of this nonsense they've all bought
into this lock stock and barrel leftist
cannot be allowed to take control of
this government if this is going to be
their mentality if liberals take control
of government your taxes go up if
leftist take control your government
your rights are in danger horrifying it
we'll get to that in a second first
nobody wants to feel like they're
overpaying while shopping online but did
you know there's an easy way to get the
lowest price it's called honey and
everyone deserves to know about it honey
is a free shopping tool that
automatically saves you money by
searching the internet for the best
promo codes whenever you shop online
that means you get the best deals
without even trying on sites like Amazon
eBay Walmart Macy's Domino's and more
honey does it all for you it always
applies the biggest discount right at
checkout honey has over 10 million
members over a hundred thousand
five-star reviews honey members have
already saved more than eight hundred
million dollars not bad for something
that's completely free and takes just
two clicks to install never worry if
you're overpaying again with honey you
can always shop with confidence knowing
you're getting the best deal I've
learned a bunch what they call honey
gold over and over because I shop at
Amazon all the time there's no reason
not to add honey to your browser today
it's free to use it installs in just two
clicks get honey for free at join honey
calm /ban that's two words
join honey calm / Ben honey is the
easiest way to save money while shopping
online again I have it running in the
background in my computer at all times
so anytime I go shopping for anything
honey is working to save me money it can
do the same for you and it's free to
join go check them out join the honey
comm / Ben join the honey comm / Ben
will start working for you and saving
you money okay so other Democratic
candidates come out and they mirror the
AOC Ilhan Omar Nancy Pelosi Eli that if
you criticize Ilhan Omar you're
responsible for violence this shortly
after AOC suggests that it's like the
Holocaust to criticize Ilhan omar jay
inslee who's running a quixotic idiotic
campaign for the presidency he has no
shot he's tweeting out president Trump's
inflammatory and dangerous rhetoric
toward el Han Omar is jeopardizing her
safety he is deliberately putting her
and all Muslim Americans in harm's way
question how is he putting all the
Muslim Americans in harm's way they're
all Muslims did all Muslim Americans
call 911 some people did something did
all of them suggest radically
anti-semitic stuff did all of them do
that stuff also where has he called for
violence what is your standard for
incitement if it's this low then it
seems to me that your criticism of
President Trump is inciting violence
against President Trump held somebody
set himself on fire in front of the
White House on Friday Elizabeth Warren
says the president is inciting violence
against a sitting congresswoman and an
entire group of Americans based on their
religion how how I need an explanation
how did he incite violence against an
entire group of Americans based on their
religion it seems to me that if you're
talking about inciting violence against
groups based on religion your party
Elizabeth Warren is in the midst of
doing that if we're gonna use your
standard of incitement when you're the
ones who are propping up anti-semites
open anti-semitic Rashidah Talib and
Ilhan Omar Elizabeth Warren knows better
than this but she's a joke who's looking
for attention
she says that the president's rhetoric
is disgusting it's shameful and any
elected leader who refuses to condemn it
shares responsibility for it I see I see
so if President Trump says something and
then people don't condemn it as
incitement then they are responsible for
violence - so everyone is responsible
for violence the only criteria here is
that you have to be on the you have to
be on the right
that's it Cory Booker does the same
thing then all this is in bad faith
senator Booker tweets out Trump's recent
attacks on Ilhan Omar unacceptable this
is the same language that gives
extremists license to carry out violence
against our Muslim brothers and sisters
I cannot express to you how it really is
it is truly unamerican in his unamerican
she suggests that everyone who disagrees
with you is inciting violence against
you it is an unamerican thing the First
Amendment says that you get to speak
incitement is a legal standard
incitement is illegal if I incite
someone to violence if I go over to my
producers and I say go kill X today I am
responsible for inciting violence that's
a legal standard I can be arrested for
it to equate speech with violence is the
essence of tyranny here's cory booker
doing it on Face the Nation are you
offended by the congresswoman's language
some people did something III think that
it is what she is experiencing right now
she does not deserve from what she said
in her speech she does not deserve the
kind of vicious hate-filled attacks that
she's experiencing threats on her life
right now we all as Americans just say
that's outrageous unacceptable what
Donald Trump is doing is he's making
life dangerous not just for her but for
other Muslim Americans now look how he
avoids the question right the question
was what do you think of her statement
and he says well her treatment is really
bad that's not the question I agree
anyone who issues a death threat to
Ilhan Omar should promptly be arrested
that's true also what she said was
egregious also she has said nothing but
egregious things apparently since
joining Congress Hin you and your party
keep covering for her cory booker then
beta O'Rourke who by the way is sinking
in the polls like a stone as well he
should be bait oh he comes out and does
the same routine
[Music]
against congresswoman Omar against our
fellow Americans who happened to be
Muslim this is part and parcel of what
we've seen from an administration
[Music]
okay that happens to be a lie okay this
is the this this administration has not
defined all Mexican immigrants as
rapists and criminals he suggested also
that Trump called immigrants animals
that is not true he called them as
thirteen animals but this this whole
routine is so well coordinated that it
has to be coming top-down it has to be
that Ilhan Omar trotted out this garbage
defense and the Democratic leadership
decided it's time for everybody to get
on the same page and everybody is now
going to kowtow to the woke portion of
the base that chants speech at violence
at speeches like mine and equate actual
acts of violence against right-wingers
with speech by right-wingers that's
what's going on here
now hilariously enough it is fascinating
to see how Rasheeda Talib and Ilhan Omar
and aosu truly have the Democratic
leadership by the cojones here you know
they really haven't I mean it's it's
amazing Rasheeda Talib in the midst of
all this in the midst of all the
Democrats coming up and defending and
defending Ilhan Omar for saying garbage
things on a regular basis Rasheeda Talib
who also says garbage things on a
regular basis but happens to be slightly
more sophisticated about it she tweets
out they put us in photos when they want
to show our party is diverse however
when we asked to be at the table or
speak up about issues that impact who we
are what we fight for and why we ran in
the first place we are ignored to truly
100 our diversity is to never silenced
us so in other words you have to shut up
and listen to us that's Rasheeda Talib
saying that to Nancy Pelosi you need to
shut up and listen to us and Nancy
Pelosi being a doof immediately falls
prey to this in practice in practice now
why should why should people take
Rasheeda to lieb's views seriously she's
one of 435 elected Congress people why
should her views have outsized impact
particularly since Rasheeda Talib
happens to be a radical anti-semite who
spends a lot of time associating with
radical anti-semites you'll recall that
there was a person named Abbas huh me
day he tweeted out quote I was honored
to be a congresswoman Rasheeda Talib
swearing-in ceremony in Detroit and
private dinner afterward with the entire
family friends and
to us across the country hashtag
Palestine hashtag tweet tweet or thobe
hashtag Rasheeda Talib he tweeted that
out so who exactly is about Zalman day
who's standing there in the picture
presenting her a picture of herself
here's a tweet he sent over the weekend
quote the dangerous part about a Jew
landing on the moon is that three
thousand years from now Zionist ideology
could claim ownership of the moon what a
nice guy
but the good news is that he has lots of
tweets like this two days later hey two
days later this would have been
yesterday quote so okay so the guy named
Jonah Lieberman tweeted American Jewish
leaders led the fight to publicly
undermine ohana Marv after a comments
about AIPAC to make up for that they now
need to lead the fight in her favor
about how many tweets I concur with this
Jew American Jews started this slander
against Ilhan Omar because she called
AIPAC out this is well documented oh
really
is it well documented cuz it seems like
everybody who's pro-israel and
pro-jewish pointed out to what she said
was anti-semitic including Democratic
leaders over the weekend about hummina
Arab Jews who turned criminal Zionists
don't cry about not being wanted by your
Arab nations you can't be trusted just
like European occupiers enjoy Poland one
day with the rest of your fellow
European criminal invaders that was your
choice not the choice of the Arab
countries in other words destroy Israel
send all the Jews back to Poland Abbas
Hamid a close friend or Ishita too late
clearly this is a person whose views
should be taken incredibly seriously I
mean this is a person who she should she
needs to be taken seriously and my
criticism of her probably is inciting
violence according to the Democratic
standard if I read those tweets and I
pointed out that this person is a close
friend of Rasheeda Talib then this
obviously is inciting violence in some
way never mind that people do this kind
of stuff to every public figure
never mind that I myself have been taken
out of context repeatedly routinely
throughout my career all of that is free
speech I may dislike it I may fight back
against it it's not incitement it's
amazing now in a second I'll show you
that the Democratic leadership the
Democratic leadership is deeply
uncomfortable with all of this but they
have to pretend to like it it's pretty
incredible as I say how these new
democratic congresswoman because they
are woke and diverse and intersectional
really have the Democratic Party by the
short hairs is pretty incredible
we'll get to that in just one second
first you're gonna have to go over to
Daley wire calm and subscribe for $9.99
a month
you can subscribe over at daily wire.com
when you do you get the rest of this
show live you get two additional hours
of this show every day we are working
hard for your money go check it out
right now
annual subscription you get this the
very greatest and beverage vessels the
leftist years hot or cold tumbler gaze
upon it and be rejuvenated simply by
seeing it imagine what it could do for
you if you held it in your hands all you
have to do is go subscribe for $99 a
year over at daily wear comm you also
get our Sunday special early we have all
sorts of great Sunday specials coming up
you also get to be part of our mailbag
so will answer your questions will
answer questions sometimes during the
live radio show in the middle of the
breaks so plenty of great stuff going on
when you subscribe go check it out right
now please subscribe at YouTube in
iTunes as well so you can get all of our
stuff for free most of our stuff for
free anyway and leave us a review we
always appreciate it we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay so the Democrats are clearly
uncomfortable with all of this but
they've been forced into a corner by
featuring he woke Congress people hoping
to duplicate the Obama 2012 coalition Oh
we'll get out sighs minority votes if we
feature these woke Congress people now
Nancy Pelosi has been boxed in Nancy
Pelosi I've never seen Nancy Pelosi
looked more uncomfortable than when she
is talking about Rashida to leave Ilhan
Omar and AOC because she knows that
these radical Congress people are
driving the Democratic Party away from
the middle of the country and I don't
mean like the physical middle of the
country I mean from anyone who considers
themselves moderate or independent or
even liberal these knew what Congress
people are driving those people away
from the Democratic Party Nancy Pelosi
hates it you can see it she's with
Leslie strolling on 60 minutes here's
how it sounded you have these wings AOC
and her group on one side it's like five
people know the progressive group it's
more than that is it I'm a progressive
yeah so there's Nancy Pelosi trying to
cut AOC dead it's like five people that
wing and then when Lesley Stahl says no
those are the progressives she has no no
no I'm the progressive okay Nancy then
take control your damn party now I've
heard what a clever manipulator you are
I keep hearing from the left that you
are a Machiavellian politician bar none
that you are the queen of the House of
Representatives so what are you doing
about this anything or are you just
gonna I mean we already know you've
already decided that you're gonna kowtow
to all of these women who say awful
things on a regular basis you're going
to kowtow to them because you are too
scared of pissing off your own base all
right well live with the consequences
and don't pretend that it's incitement
to criticize you or them politics is
about criticism politics is about a back
and forth politics is about the
dialectic process of finding truth by
discussion and if you don't like that
then you are a problem if you don't like
that then you are the one who is
imposing tyranny from above truly
amazing
but this mentality has spread throughout
the Democratic Party the Democratic
Party the top levels of it and the
progressive woek base they've they've
decided to participate in this Maoist
system where either you must shut up and
listen to the most intersectional among
us or we are going to call you out as
racist and as inciting violence
so that means the only thing that you
can do is basically lay prostrate before
your intersectional betters and if you
lay prostrate before your intersectional
betters then everything will be all
right that's the only way you can avoid
blame and that's why you end up with
pieces like this in the New England
Journal of Medicine ok the New England
Journal of Medicine has a piece today
from a doctor named Deborah Cohan and
the piece says quote I am racist shaped
by the sometimes subtle tendrils of
white supremacy deeply embedded in our
culture I mean this not as a
sanctimonious admission of guilt but as
a call to self-reflection and action for
us white physicians oh is that what you
mean by it
or do you mean that now no one can
criticize you because you have confessed
your racism in this now is struggle
session in the pages of the New England
Journal of Medicine what does this have
to do with medicine the answer of course
is nothing temperate Cohen writes not
dealing with our racism is a
manifestation of our privilege and
reinforces a system that allows white
physicians to dip into the waters of
self-inquiry only when it feels safe so
you'll be allowed to speak so long as
what you speak is the language of
surrender to the intersectional racism
of the left so if you say listen I'm a
racist and I accept that I can't
challenge the views of anyone who
disagrees with me who ranks higher on
the victimhood scale and intersection
then you can talk but that's the only
thing we're gonna allow you to say into
this culture wild leftists are now
pushing an even more insane proposal
Benjamin Applebaum who's on the New York
Times editorial board one of the worst
editorial boards in the country he has a
piece today called everyone's income
taxes should be public so into this woke
culture this culture where we are going
to shame you if you disagree we are also
going to ask that everyone's tax returns
be public so that we can find people and
destroy their lives it's pretty
astonishing now I have a solution how
about the New York Times editorial board
goes first is there anything good about
the idea that why is everyone privy to
my finances why should they be privy to
your finances the only reason to do any
of this the only reason the left is
pushing any of this is to forward the
bullying culture that they have created
for themselves the is to is to push the
idea that that if you do not do what
they want on your tax returns if you
earns
much money you are bad you are morally
bankrupt and therefore they can attack
you if you are white they can morally
attack you until you suggest that you
are in fact part of a racist
superstructure in which case you're
allowed to talk and if you won't do
either of those things if you won't
throw open your doors to the to the
Maoist then they then you then they will
target you and they will call you a
racist bigoted sexist homophobic citing
violence all this stuff is so disturbing
this is not liberalism liberalism is
dead this is the left
liberalism used to be about we want a
little more government intervention in
the economy I disagreed with that but
that was the case
now liberalism is about confessing your
racism in public even if you're not a
racist
now now leftism is about throw open the
doors of your tax returns so we can all
examine in detail whether we approve of
your earning and spending habits now
it's about if you criticize us thinking
you're inciting violence you want to
break up a democracy you wanna break up
a republic this is how you do it right
here and we're watching it happen okay
meanwhile something hilarious did happen
over the weekend it's been pretty funny
it's a president Trump as we talked
about on Friday I apparently floated a
proposal whereby people who are coming
into the country illegally and for which
the federal government did not have the
resources because Democrats have not
provided the funding necessary to keep
families together at the border
President Trump suggested okay instead
of just shipping them to the local
border town instead of just sending them
to El Paso and letting them roam around
in El Paso how about this you guys in
the left you don't want to provide me
the funding and since you don't want to
provide me the funding and since you
also have created sanctuary cities how
about we send them to you and you deal
with it
President Trump tweeted out Democrats
must change the immigration laws fast if
not sanctuary cities must immediately
act take care of the illegal immigrants
and this includes gang members drug
dealers human traffickers and criminals
of all shapes sizes and kinds change the
laws now now the point that he is making
here of course is that if you are wildly
Pro open borders then you should
probably feel the consequences of your
decision making he says so interesting
to see the mayor of Oakland and other
sanctuary cities do not want our
currently detained immigrants have to
release due to the ridiculous Corner
20-day rule if they don't want to serve
our nation by taking care of them why
should other cities and towns there is
nothing wrong with what he is saying
here
you may not like President Trump but
what he is saying here is true if you
are a if you if you believe that illegal
immigration only adds benefit to your
city and if you believe that the
president has been overstating the
problems and if you believe that the
only humane treatment is catch and
release of these folks into American
societies they can live and work in
America why not send them to places
where they're even more protected like
sanctuary cities shouldn't they be
cheering now it's funny there's some
people on the right say well isn't this
going to make it easier for these people
to escape into the system Trump's point
is they're already escaping into the
system they already are and the people
who are feeling the brunt of that are
not people who approve the system so if
they're going to escape into the system
anyway if these people are going to be
released into the system and never show
up again and just overstay they're
temporary work visas
well then maybe they should live in the
areas where Democrats keep saying they
want them and hilariously enough
Democrats are upset about this which
does demonstrate a peculiar hypocrisy on
the part of Democrats they're the best
of the best element of this over the
weekend was cher so cher who is a is a
crazy left winger she tweeted out I
understand helping struggling immigrants
but my city Los Angeles isn't taking
care of its own what about the 50,000
plus American citizens who live on the
streets people who live below the
poverty line and they're hungry if my
state can't take care of its own
many are vets how can it take care of
more welcome to the dark side Cher
welcome to the Republican Party that's
the case the President Trump is been
making I guess that sheriff or new head
of DHS right you know that's president
from that's his entire case we have a
lot of costs in this country we can't
take care of everybody who wants to be
on welfare we can't just bring people in
here and put them on food stamps or
state programs so cher I guess is now
recognizing oh wait there are finite
resources and when you let in an
unlimited number of people to take
advantage of finite resources you end up
with the shortage hilariously enough
it's not only Cher it's Cory Booker
struggling to maintain relevance in a
crowded Democratic field he was on Face
the Nation over the weekend and he says
it is less safe for us to release
illegal immigrants into sanctuary cities
oh really oh really senator Booker do
you think this is an empty threat by the
president though to talk about busing
people from the border into these
sanctuary cities he likes to create
frictions sometimes to jump start he
says a Congress
it's not acne you say friction I say
he's trying to pit americans against
each other and make us less safe because
what you're seeing now so you take that
threat seriously III take this he is
injecting fear into our country and so
if he was looking to solve a problem he
wouldn't be doing things to divide this
country against itself where of any
anybody that's trying to tell you to be
afraid in the strongest country in the
world as opposed to showing our strength
and our courage by pulling people
together to find common sense solutions
to solve this problem
he says it's less safe weird weird and
he says that it tears us apart to send
illegal immigrants to cities where they
will be the most welcome odd Cory Booker
I'm strange it's it's amusing to watch
as the as the Democrats you know
basically embrace the Republican premise
on this entire argument while at the
same time maintaining they won't do
anything about it it's not just on that
score by the way where Democrats are
embracing the Republican premise well
I'm not doing anything about it
Bernie Sanders was on the campaign trail
over the weekend and senator Sanders has
been caught up in a bit of an awkward
situation it turns out that he is a
millionaire and as a socialist this is a
not great thing so Bernie Sanders had to
explain that it's not criminal for him
to be rich
[Applause]
my food has always been that we need a
progressive tax system which demands
that the wealthiest people in this
country finally translated the five or
six languages oh well I don't apologize
for writing a book that was number one
on the New York Times bestseller list
and is being translated into other
languages as we speak I don't apologize
for that either the difference is I like
capitalism I think it's good dirty
little secret about democratic politics
they all like capitalism including
Bernie Sanders
I know uncomfortable facts but Bernie
Sanders actually likes capitalism he
just won't say that publicly and I would
love for somebody to press him he's
holding his first press scrum by the way
two months after launch amazing how the
press haven't made a big deal out of
that speaking of press malfeasance
there is polling out that shows that the
American people do not believe that they
got a tax cut from President Trump's tax
cuts and yet virtually everyone did the
New York the Tax Policy Center estimates
that 65% of people paid less under the
new tax law and just 6% of people paid
more I'd be in the 6% by the way other
analyses reached similar conclusions the
Joint Committee on taxation Congress is
nonpartisan team of tax analysts found
that every income group would see a tax
cut on average in a December 2017
analysis from the Institute on taxation
and economic policy found every income
group in every state would pay less on
average under the law in 2019 and yet
the vast majority of people do not
understand that they got a tax cut and
now it's hilarious the media are saying
why don't people know that why don't
people because you said that they would
not because you claims that it was a tax
cut that was created to benefit the rich
so you lied say you lied that's how you
end up in this situation without media
lies Democrats would have almost nothing
almost nothing alright time for some
things I like and then some things that
I hate so things that I like today so
you know what let's just do that Game of
Thrones episode let's do a brief
breakdown I came to throats the spoilers
ahead spoilers had for those who don't
watch Game of Thrones
fast forward maybe
or three minutes in this and then we'll
be back with some things I hate but the
the okay so Game of Thrones episode I
enjoyed it I thought it was good I
thought it was slow
I kept thinking okay you guys have like
what eight hours to wrap this whole
thing up and we're gonna waste twenty
minutes of this on lingering looks like
just people staring at each other that's
what we're gonna do or an army arriving
at Winterfell yeah I got it like from
the first shot then the army was coming
to Winterfell sort of sort of sort of
got that part also I will say that bran
whoever plays bran that kid they cast
him when he was a kid and you never know
when you cast a kid whether the kid's
gonna turn out to be a good actor or
whether the kid is just gonna turn out
to be a stump and neon taster my Twitter
father tweeted out and I think this is
right that bran is basically the Hodor
of looking at people but ever every time
bran looks at somebody it's the same
look so he just sort of sits there next
to her for the entire episode there are
a couple of good scenes the scene where
John finds out his lineage is pretty
great then that was pretty much the only
terrific scene the the how to train your
dragon' sequence with Dany and John was
a little long and we all sort of saw it
coming
but it's all a setup anyway everybody
knows that this is a setup for the big
battle so slightly disappointed yes
did it have its moments yes is is Danny
going to turn into a mad Targaryen the
odds are good the odds are good that
Danny turns into a mad Targaryen before
all of this is said and done okay so
there is your brief Game of Thrones
expert nothing update nothing nothing
actually happens in the episode except
that John finds out what's going on
everything else is filler Cersei drinks
and enunciates the letter T very clearly
a lot and you're on shows up and make
some jokes make some sex jokes and there
are some boobs because we have to point
out that this is HBO and we have to
remind people that you're paying
subscription so you can see boobs but
other than that not much happen is that
a fair summation guys if it's a pretty
fair summation in the episode okay so
alright other things that I like is
still did I enjoy it yeah I mean I like
the game of Thrones is back alright
other things that I like so that it's
just an amazing sports story Tiger Woods
won the Masters he the last time he won
the Masters was a solid decade ago and
there's this great video of him hugging
his
after winning the Masters now Tiger
obviously was at the top of the sporting
world it's rare to see somebody humbled
the way the tiger woods' was right he
came out that he was stepping every porn
star during a 57 mile radius and then it
broke up his marriage it was really
quite terrible for him and for his
family obviously that he was doing all
of those things and then he got injured
and he was off the scene for a solid
decade and comes back in his mid 40s to
win the Masters pretty amazing story
here's a video of him hugging his owners
pretty cool charlie
was it even born when his father won a
major the last time in 2008 pretty cool
stuff so I guess it was 2008 pretty neat
stuff from from Tiger Woods and it's a
great redemption story so there's this
great there's from his first masters
when there's this great video of him
hugging his dad wearing nearly an
identical shirt and then you fast
forward 15 years and now he's hugging
his son
pretty cool stuff okay time for some
things that I hate so first thing that I
hate there is a professor named
Alexander McNabb at Barnard College and
he wanted to enter a room he wanted to
enter a room that require a building
that required after 11:00 p.m. that
required him to show ID he refused to
show ID and then he became belligerent
with campus officers he then encouraged
activists to spread the video claiming
racism and the officers have been placed
on leave here's a little bit of the
video
[Music]
ok so they showed the video and in the
video he starts showing them his ID
after making a big scene so he's a
student not a professor sorry and here
is the way that this was covered by the
Washington Post
Alexander McNabb was hungry it was 11:30
p.m. on Thursday and the Columbia
University senior had just left his
late-night afro beats dance practice he
had work to do and his anthropology
thesis was looming so the 23 year old
pulled out his phone to check a Facebook
page where students can post and find
the most universally reliable staple on
American college campuses free food
other students had just deposited party
leftovers in the nearby Barnard College
Library where Columbia students are
welcome to study McNabb had it that way
by the end of the night he would find
himself the latest subject of another
viral video the kind that receives the
tense that revives the tense
conversation communities are having
nationwide about police use of force
racial profiling in the
risks that come with being a person of
color in the United States okay that's a
lie
basically what happened here according
to Andy know is that this guy walked
into the library refused to show ID you
can see by the way that one of the
officers there is black he refused to
show ID and then after refusing to show
ID and screaming at the officers he was
accosted by the officers and then he and
and then he refused to go along with
them and then he encouraged people to
show the video around as though he'd
been victimized in some sort of racial
crime at Barnard College this prompted
all of these protesters to show up and
scream no justice no peace
if these racist police pretty pretty
amazing stuff and then the deans of
Columbia released a groveling statement
saying that the belligerents student was
a victim of racism and encouraging the
student body to engage in social justice
programs the investigation still is not
complete it's a set up video pretty
obviously and yet it is treated as
though it is real by the mainstream
media because they have to have
incidents that they can claim are
indicative of broader American racism
even if those incidents seem to be
fabricated from the outset so solid
stuff they're already well we will be
back here a little bit later today with
two hours more of content we will see
you then I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam Tsai
Yvette's audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
hey everyone its Andrew clave and host
of the Andrew Clavin show is the
struggle real I don't think so this is a
country where almost anyone can do
almost anything so what is everybody
complaining about
I'm Andrew Clavin that's on the Andrew
Clavin show